in this video i want to clarify two
ideas that we talk about on a regular
basis but are really kind of muddled up
in our popular language and these are
the ideas of mass
mass and weight
and first i'll tell you what they are
and then we'll talk about how they are
muddled up so mass is literally there's
a couple of ways to view mass one way to
view masses and this is not a technical
definition will give you a sense of it
is how much stuff
how much stuff there is so this is
similar to saying
matter
so if i have more molecules of a given
mass
or of of a given mass i will have a
total of more mass so if i have more
atoms i will have more mass so how much
stuff there is of something and i want
to be careful with this definition right
here because there are other things that
aren't what would be what we would
traditionally associate with matter once
we start going into more fancy physics
that still will exhibit mass so another
way to to define mass is how does how
does something react to a specific force
and we already learned from newton's
second law that if you have if you have
a given force and you have more mass you
will accelerate less if you have less
mass you'll accelerate more so how
something responds to force
how
something
responds to force
to a given force
something with
lower mass will accelerate more for a
given force something with higher mass
will accelerate less
now weight
weight is the force of gravity on a mass
or on an object so this is
the force
force of gravity
gravity on
on
an object
and just to think about the difference
here let's think about
let's think about i guess myself sitting
on earth
so if i'm on earth my mass is 70
kilograms
my mass let me do this in a new color so
my mass
my mass is 70 kilograms there's 70
kilograms of stuff that constitute sal
but my weight is not 70 kilograms i mean
you'll often hear people say i weigh 70
kilograms and that's all right in just
conversational usage but that is not
technically correct because weight is
the force that earth is pulling down or
i should say the force of gravity on my
mass and so the my weight
my weight let me think about the weight
for a second
the weight is going to be equal to the
is is going to be equal to and the
gravitational field at earth so let me
just like we did hopefully you've
watched the video on gravity or if you
haven't feel free to watch it but the
gravitational attraction between two
objects
so the force of gravity between two
objects is going to be
big g the universal gravitational
constant times the mass of the first
object times the mass
let me actually let me do it
times the mass of the first object times
the mass of the second object times the
mass of the second object divided by
the distance that separates the two
objects squared and if you're on earth
and if you take all of this stuff right
over here combined so if you say that
this right here is the mass of earth
mass of earth
if you say this right here is the
distance from the center to the surface
of earth because that's where i'm
sitting right now so distance
distance
from
center
to surface
of earth then all of this stuff over
here simplifies to
simplifies to what's sometimes called as
lowercase g and lowercase g is and i'm
just rounding it here 9.8 meters per
second squared so the force of gravity
for something near the surface of the
earth is going to be is going to be this
quantity right over here
times
times the mass times its mass so my
weight my weight on the surface of the
earth is this 9.8 meters per second
squared 9.8 meters per second squared
times my mass times 70 kilograms
times 70
times 70 kilograms and so this is going
to be and i could i won't do well i
could get my calculator now why don't i
just get my calculator out and do the
math i was going to round it to 10 and
say it's about 700 but let's just
actually calculate it
so we have 9.8
times 70 kilograms
so we have 686
so this gives me 686
and then the units are kilogram meters
per second squared kilogram meters per
second squared and these units kilogram
meters per second squared are the same
thing as a newton as a newton so my
weight and you'll never hear people say
this but my weight on the surface of the
earth is 686 newtons
686 newtons and notice i just said that
is my weight on the surface of the earth
because as you can imagine weight is the
force due to gravity on an object on a
mass so if i go someplace else if i go
if i go to the moon for example my
weight will change but my mass will not
so let's write this this is the weight
this is the weight on earth if i were to
take my weight on the moon
the weight
on the moon
weight on the moon
and i haven't looked this up before the
video and you can verify this for me if
you like but i've been told that the
gravitational force on the moon or the
gravitational attraction at the surface
of the moon is about one-sixth that of
the surface of the earth so on my weight
on the moon will be roughly 1 6
roughly 1 6 of my weight on the earth
times 686 newtons so that gives me a
little bit over what is that 100 and 114
maybe i'll just get the calculator out
my brain is always operates a little bit
slower while i'm
recording videos yo i got it right right
114 so that gives us
114 approximately 114 newtons so this is
the thing i really want to emphasize in
weight is a force due to gravity on an
object your weight changes from planet
to planet you go on your weight would
actually even change as you as you as if
you went to a very high altitude because
you're getting slightly further it would
be immeasurably small but you're getting
slightly further from the center of the
earth
your weight would change an
imperceptible amount in fact because the
earth is not a perfect sphere
because the earth is not a perfect
sphere it's slightly it's often referred
to as an oblique spheroid your weight is
actually slightly different your weight
is actually slightly different on
different parts of the earth if you went
to the poles versus the equator you
would have a slightly different a
slightly different weight your mass does
not change it doesn't matter where you
go assuming that you don't have some
type of nuclear reaction going on inside
of you your mass does not change so your
mass
mass does not change but it does not
change depending on where you are
now you might be saying hey look you
know i don't deal with kilograms and
newtons and all of this i i operate in
america and in america we talk about
pounds it's pounds appropriate and yes
pounds is a unit of weight
so if i say
if i say that i weigh
160 pounds
160 pounds
this is indeed weight i'm saying that
the force of gravity on me is
and sixty pounds but then you might say
well what is math then if you're talking
about if you're talking about the
english system or sometimes called the
imperial system and here i will
introduce you to a concept that very few
people know it's kind of a good trivial
concept
the unit of mass the unit of mass so
let's just be clear here the unit of
mass
on in the imperial system
mass is called the slug
mass
the unit of mass is called the slug so
if you wanted to figure out how many
slugs you are
so your weight the force of gravity on
you is 160 pounds 160
pounds
this is going to be equal to if you were
to take if you were to calculate if you
were to calculate all of this stuff the
force of gravity on the surface of earth
but if you were to do it in if you were
doing it imperial units instead of
getting 9.8 meters per second squared
you would get
instead of 9.8 meters per second squared
you would get 32
feet
per second squared which is also the
acceleration on near the surface of the
earth due to gravity in feet and seconds
as opposed to meters and seconds and
then this is times your mass times your
mass
in slugs
in
in slugs so to figure it out you divide
both sides by 32 feet per second squared
so let's do that let's divide both sides
by 32 feet per second squared divide
both sides by 32
feet per second squared
cancels out and then let me get my
calculator out
so i have 160 pounds divided by 32 feet
per second squared and i get exactly 5.
i should have been able to do that in my
head so i get 5 and the units here in
the numerator i have pounds
i have pounds
and then i'm dividing by feet per second
squared that's the same thing as
multiplying by seconds squared per feet
and these units five pounds second
squareds over feet this is the same
thing as a slug so if i weigh
160 pounds my mass is going to be equal
to
my mass is going to be equal to 5 slugs
if my mass is 70 kilograms mass is 70
kilograms my weight is
686 newtons so hopefully that clarifies
things a little bit